pierre henry président de france prat
ternie t bonds soit pierre henry merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
humiliation harcèlement quotidien des
migrants à calais c'est l entoure on
vient d'entendre les ong human rights
watch qui pointe du doigt directement
l'état votre réaction sur ces
accusations
écoutez la situation est parfaitement
documenté et depuis longtemps a calé en
l'occurrence nous savons que depuis
2016 il y a environ un millier de
personnes qui se concentre sur le
littoral calaisien mais qui cherche à
rejoindre à toutes fins la grande
bretagne et depuis cette date oui nous
savons qu'il y à des opérations de
répéter des forces de l'ordre et qui
parfois souvent se transforme en
violence est ce que l'on peut qualifier
de violence le fait de les serrer des
tentes alors qu'il fait très froid est
ce que l'on peut qualifier de violence
le fait d'être harcelés alors que l'on
manque de tout le travail des forces de
l'ordre et un travail extrêmement
complexe ce que les autorités françaises
leur demande de faire a calé et d'une
certaine manière elle c'est absurde je
rappelle que la grande bretagne ait
adopté le break site est sortie de
l'union européenne en promettant à ses
la population qu'il n'y aurait plus de
migration vers la grande-bretagne or il
n'en est rien plus vous renforcer
les contrôles plus vous fermer la route
migratoire et plus vous fait courir des
risques aux personnes qui veulent
emprunter ce sont des milliers de
personnes qui depuis le début
de l'année ont tenté le passage de la
manche pour aller vers la grande
bretagne
donc je pense qu'il faut sortir de cette
situation est évidemment à inventer
autre chose
sortons pierre ory vous qu'il
connaissait bien le sujet comment on en
sort mais on en sort en essayant de
construire une boîte migration légale
notamment pour les membres de famille
ou encore pour les mineurs qui sont
nombreux a calé je rappelle que c'est ce
qui avait été tentée en
2016 2017 il y avait vu un amendement
qui a été adopté
par le législateurs britanniques qui
permettait de faire en sorte que les
gens puissent rejoindre légalement la
grande bretagne a pas d'autre solution
parce que là on est dans une impasse
totale la grande-bretagne paye la france
pour que
nous empêchions les personnes de
rejoindre
les pays
l'est l'angleterre l'irlande etc donc ça
c'est pas possible on peut pas continuer
de cette manière et il faut sortir de
cette situation ou encore une fois le
nombre le les flux sont relativement bas
un millier de personnes mais continue et
donc il y à un certain nombre de gens
qui sont à calais qui ont vocation à
demander les îles en grande bretagne et
je m'étonne moi des déclarations du
gouvernement britannique quand il
explique par exemple il va accueillir
vingt mille réfugiés en provenance
d'afghanistan mais vous savez vous avez
un certain nombre de qui sont à calais
qui sont afghans mais qui veulent
rejoindre la grande bretagne commençons
par là aux enterrements là la grande
bretagne ne prend pas sa part c'est ce
que vous dit en substance il faut les
exhorter voir les contraintes peut-être
à apprendre cette base là bas il faut
absolument d'abord c'est un énorme
mensonge
que
le bric site le brésil n'a rien empêché
du tout et tous ceux qui
improvise allemand pour empêcher la
migration se trompe il faut évidemment
demandé à la grande bretagne une
approche beaucoup plus
pragmatique beaucoup plus humaine et
puis ici
éviter que les forces de police fait son
travail
évidemment absurde merci beaucoup pierre
henry président de france terre n'était
d'avoir été avec merdouille de m'avoir
invité on dirait que je vous en prie en
direct sur arte france